today we're going to have a conversation
about dating yes yes yes yes yes I know
crazy
um so my first question
what is your ideal first date
oh
you start with me yeah okay cool you did
get this seat today this is the starting
seat
no I know uh I would say something kind
of Outdoors definitely multiple
locations not necessarily eating
involved I don't think people or humans
in general look particularly attractive
when eating but um yeah something
outdoors I love a good roof Terrace you
know I like to see like a Skyline you
know you got a late one by the way
um yeah so yeah something like that
maybe somewhere in the woods or
something like that something to do with
nature and yeah an activity that
actually allows you to you know bond
with the person and what could a girl do
on this date that would make you not
want a second date
uh I mean if she's just on your phone
too much I mean almost on your phone at
all like unless it's like a massive
emergency I think the most important
person is like the person right in front
of you you should pay attention to them
um you know especially in a date
scenario where you're literally vetting
for this person whether you know you
find them really attractive or arousing
or what kind of long-term or short-term
interaction you want to have with them
in future I think it's important to be
present in that vetting process
what about you ideal first date the
beach okay like the beach sunset Ocean
like a little picnic blanket yo yeah the
beach sound really like that I know I
know you're in a relationship now but if
you were dating again what would be
something a guy could do on a date that
would make you not want to speak to him
again
um
trying to act like you know when a guy
tries to act like he's the man but he's
like he's football really trying to let
me know like yeah I have money yeah I
have this [__] so being super like cocky
like in your face about and most of the
time when I like that they don't
actually have what they're saying they
have like yeah yeah so it just it just
gives me the ick like I don't like it
even if you do have money
um I feel like that's not the reason why
I'm there right now like I just want to
kind of know you yeah but something a
guy could say like what would he say
like he would mention his car or like
what what's an example just for the guys
watching like what not to do on a date
okay for example um so this isn't a guy
that I was dating or anything but we're
just talking
um I work in a nightclub so he was like
trying to like talk to me like that
um and then yeah he was just telling me
with every single conversation if we're
talking about houses to be like yeah
yeah my parents have three houses but
obviously I don't really care about
money or like we'll be talking and he'll
be like yeah like I have about 10
watches but I don't care I'm like yes
you do you care oh so you kept bringing
up the money yeah every single little
thing
you know it's a crazy thing for me when
guys bring up height when like I won't
bring it up I'm like well I hate girls
that are shorter than me like I just
like I mean I hate girls that are taller
than me they'll just really make it a
point how tall they are but I just I
don't like no it's funny it's like
because I don't usually bring it up but
if I'm taller than a guy even if it's
but like because if it's a little bit I
don't really care but it's like I'm like
why are you bringing this up like I'll
tell you I'm six foot I'm pretty tall
yeah yeah I'm very tall uh so what about
you ideal first date ideal first day I
think
um I don't I'm not really into like
dinners or anything fancy or anything
like that I think the best dates that I
have been on involved doing something
that is going to help so like I don't
know let's say um there's not really
much time I live in Brighton um a lot of
the guys that I date are from London
um so if we get a chance to kind of meet
it's normally on I'm quite a busy person
and that sometimes I quite a bit as well
so if we get to meet is normally when
they have to go and pick something up
from somewhere like help the family or
you know so when I if I can actually see
the guy in his like natural environment
as well I could literally consider that
a day or even go into like Ikea or
something you know or go into this great
ideal first day it's Ikea I think do you
know what I could actually say that
because I was I I've asked a lot of
people would you be up for going to Ikea
at night you know
um kind of quirky but yeah so why do you
date guys from London if you're because
Brandon's like two hours from here isn't
it an hour and a half all right that's
pretty far like why is there something
wrong with the guys in Brighton no not
really I just I tend to I don't know I
just tend to date guys that from it just
happens they're just from London you
know I'm just wondering what makes them
better than the guys in Brighton there's
there's nothing okay you can't really
like say that so what happens is for
some reason let's say if I'm on a dating
app most guys are from London that
that's all that's all that happens and I
have dated people from Brighton before
it's just you know it's just a majority
are from London that's all okay and it
kind of first date I would give you the
egg the egg yeah like something that
could be a big just for the guys
watching so I would say don't bring up
other women
um that's one
um or in general I'm quite
um attracted to intelligence so if
somebody's Loki stupid that really just
ruins everything yeah
okay
what about you
um well at this point in my life
um it's not so much about the activity
it's more about the connection so we
could be doing anything we could be a
meal or having an intimate like date
where I cook or she cooks or whatever
it's more about just the connection so
as long as we're genuinely engaged and
laughing and just having a good time
then it's a good date pretty much you
know what I'm saying
so where would you take her
give me an example of where you could do
that well
something like ice skating
or something like golf mini golf there's
tons of places like in London for stuff
like that but generally anywhere where
we can have a good conversation and
actually get to know each other we can
pretty much happen anywhere but um yeah
mini golf
um ice skating
a good dinner something like that and
what the heck
guys don't really get the egg but but
like what a turn off anyways being into
not exactly having any thoughts of her
own and being to and everything she does
being dictated to her by her friends or
social media that's a just a hyper turn
off for me like what's something a girl
could say to you that indicates that
she's just controlled by social media uh
what do I bring to the table
[Laughter]
is that common have girls said that to
you often on a date
um well because
um I'm pretty much traditional so I'm
used to paying for everything and
whatnot but um I have been in situations
where somebody thought I wasn't being
engaged in at the time
and
um
that's because I'm I'm more I tend to be
more gentleman like or reserved in
certain situations
um
that's not necessarily a turn off but I
do realize that different people expect
different things and whatnot in
relationships and stuff so in a way it's
almost bad for me to say that I'm
someone being into social media maybe
um
a turn off for me and stuff like that
because everybody's different but social
media and all that stuff is definitely a
turn off yeah
MLD ideal first date and what's a turn
off
something that's low effort like
something like a coffee or like a couple
of drinks at a lounge that way if I like
smell crazy I can get out quickly like
45 minutes to an hour uh if she starts
talking about her ex in any way on the
first date I'm just like I'm mentally
checked out and I'm like already
strategizing how to get the hell out of
there is that common you'd be surprised
you'd be surprised so he's nodding too
is that from the guys comment how often
do girls talk about exes on a first date
too much right away yeah I would agree I
mean yeah same same as you were I would
just like check out be like yeah it's
not gonna happen I've never had that but
okay how how do they bring it up they'll
just they'll just bring it up yeah let
them go
no they like some of these girls like
you sit down you're like ready to have a
good time she's like you know my ex used
to like no be addicted to XYZ I'm like
oh okay I know now I know why you're
single like so now anytime they start
like when when the date starts to turn
into a therapy session yeah I start
drinking and I I mentally check out and
I look for an exit as soon as possible
yeah I mean I wouldn't say it happens
like pretty much all the time but 20
yeah I would say that I know you're
often than you think yeah I wouldn't say
like half but it's just like every so I
often it will happen and you're like
okay cool I know what this is yeah
uh what about you ideal first date
and what could a guy do to give you the
ick uh I like something a bit more likey
like a walk around the park with a
coffee nice chat
um and something that would give me the
ick is
if
if he
behaved in a way
where
I'd feel slightly embarrassed like a
behavior likes trying to put someone
else down to make himself feel better or
to look better that kind of makes me
feel a bit like I want to get out of
here I don't want to be here anymore
mean to the staff rude to the staff yeah
stuff like that it's not nice
so the people that you guys go on dates
with where do you typically meet them
oh
um so you can start Portage I'm in
shoreditch
I went there last night I understand
that reference I get that reference my
tongue slipped um yeah I mean I guess
some dating apps you know it's kind of
like sales always sourcing and you know
I mean I'm in in like music and
entertainments you just always around
people a lot so yeah just from being out
I guess what would you say is the number
one place what is is it dating apps
mutual friends or a shortage
well that's a tough question well do you
know what I mean I think dating apps are
pretty long
um
[Laughter]
so is there a difference in the quality
of women you meet through each place
like where would you say it's the
highest quality quality in terms of
short-term or long-term potential
long-term potential long-term potential
I mean I would say probably somewhere
like what you said yeah more like
low-key and relaxed I think girls who
you know um let's say aren't constantly
looking for a lot of attention all the
time I think they tend to be better like
long-term Partners so just anyway I
don't know maybe like a library or
something I'm really in libraries you
know but I'm just I'm just using my
imagination
so have you ever gotten a date from a
library uh actually you're never there
actually
I went on a I went on a date with uh
like a really wholesome girl and she's
like would you like to see this library
and like she showed me her book
collection and we went to this Library
yeah she was actually a really really
sweet beautiful nice girl I was
surprised first time in my life yeah I
mean they've been few and far between
um but it just happened before you just
said it like you met girls there and I'm
like wait you just said you don't got it
it's actually because a friend of mine
said this to me like the kind of girl
you mean and shortage is different you
know on a night out to the kind of girl
you meet let's say a library oh it's
short it's not a high quality I mean I'm
not just saying that like whatever just
being out I was attacked oh yeah I saw
that yeah I was attacked so I don't know
the women I haven't been impressed with
shortage women but that was my samples
it was like midnight you know
um okay what about you
um
yeah where do you typically meet um I
know you said you have a boyfriend now
where did you guys meet
industry
he just saw me in the street and he
approached me yeah you're just a
porchman then and before that where did
you typically meet guys like where was
the biggest street
I'm noticing a pack
I don't know like when you're walking in
the street and then someone's like
yo can I have your number I don't know
like that's okay so he asked you for
your number yeah no yeah yeah he was he
was very weird of it he kept on seeing
me like in the streets every single time
he saw me would like to speak and then
he eventually asked for my number okay
like did she walk by him on your way to
somewhere yeah the area that I lived in
it was like it's a very tight-knit area
like I would see him if I come out so
yeah what about you where do you it
sounded like dating apps earlier yeah so
dating apps I think 50 50 because I get
approached quite a lot on this tree as
it is and Brighton I mean we've got you
know nights out there's a lot of like
clubs and stuff so when I walk down the
street to get to the beach to hang out
with friends um there's always a lot of
different guys coming up and stuff you
know
um so mainly this but I think yeah I
would say
yeah more on an app because I think it's
just more automatic
um but yeah but I think meeting people
in person is more organic and you can
actually tell you know what they're like
kind of the first impressions and
everything straight away so yeah so you
prefer you think the quality is higher
it's much higher when you get you can
feel them out you can't feel them out
through the apps you can't put a filter
in real life too yeah
what about you
um to tell the truth I don't do so much
of the app thing at the moment but um so
it's more daily life and things like
work so for the firm I work for we're
always hiring and firing people so
um I'm always meeting tons of people I
was off for a month
um a couple of weeks ago when I came
back there was tons of new girls and
stuff and because
um I don't know if they have bad taste
or I'm genetically gifted um I tend to
get um a lot of attention and whatnot so
um when I have time I sift through
the potential suitors and whatnot so I'm
work in the street
pretty much so wait let me get this
straight so you're the place you work
will hire girls and you'll date them and
then they'll get fired
[Laughter]
um
[Applause]
for instance so it's summer right now so
we just had a ton of uni students come
in for summer jobs and whatnot um
ladies and the ages of 21 to 27 and
stuff and
I love them like older guys and stuff
like that so
um we end up talking and stuff and yeah
sometimes it goes forever sometimes it
doesn't and where did you meet your best
relationship at
um
I don't think I've had that yet you no
number one draft pick
um like tomorrow you got to get married
you gotta pick an ax
that might that might have come from a
dating app dating app okay
what about you MLB I think the majority
of women I've met and date it came from
dating apps
but recently with my newfound internet
Fame it's been Instagram
so Instagram is a little bit I don't
know I think dating apps now are just
flooded with [__] people yeah like I
think early dating apps it was good
times but like now it's Whale City and
craziness everywhere yeah that are bots
so yeah but I I definitely agree like
meeting them organically in the real
world is probably the best way okay
and where did you meet your best
relationship
she was the secretary at my job oh no
way yeah you know I have a friend that
said that you know who it is but I have
a friend Ally she says if you want to
date a certain type of guy to try to
work for them yeah she's like if you
want a dentist go be like a dental
assistant now she was the best girl ever
dated my life
what about you
um now would be dating apps
um but it wasn't always like that I
think when you're a bit younger it's
easier to get on with people that
friends of friends Associates things
like that
um that's the way it was when I was
younger but now dating apps working okay
for me okay as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible